so here's another story this is this is
more political it's kind of crazy it's
elon musk again newsweek reports elon
musk says he'll vote republican for the
first time in the next election
uh elon musk one of us uh what's it
google gobble google gobble elon musk if
i see him shortly i will tell him google
gobble yes uh do you guys know that
reference it's from a really old movie
freaks yeah where the the woman is like
at the table and all the people are
going google got another play on table
one of us so uh elon musk uh he
basically said i've voted overwhelmingly
for democrats historically like i'm not
sure i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear now this
election i will
newsweek says they're not sure if it's
the midterms the 20 2024 presidential
election which is a weird thing to add
considering he said the next election
which is literally the midterms but sure
whatever elon musk has continually been
posting memes about either the left
losing the middle the left going too far
left
or of him being like yo i'm a moderate
and this doesn't speak to me and things
like that
it's it's interesting now
i tweeted maybe the left should stop and
reflect on why they're losing so many
people
they won't do it the responses i got
were people saying like uh the ultra
rich guy who doesn't want to pay taxes
no of course he wants to be a republican
that's why all the billionaires are
constantly promoting right-wing policy
that's right
real quick since 2012 as we've covered
on the show extensively democrats have
been the party of the wealthy
it's been reiterated in 2021 with more
data showing higher income earners are
aligned with the democratic party elon
musk just paid more taxes than anyone's
ever paid in history and why didn't he
vote
four years ago republican when he was
already
still a billionaire i've seen
everyone from my broke jiu jitsu friends
to people who have health podcasts over
covid over trump because of the the the
twitter awokeness slowly go
more and more to the right you know
people wanted me to
go sort of like full right-wing actual
grifter after
my cancellation happened and i didn't do
it and so when i talk about this stuff
i'm actually talking about it from the
left i as someone who is still fairly
liberal
sees the left being pushed farther and
farther away
because it wasn't republicans who were
shutting down their businesses or gyms
over kovid it wasn't um you know i have
friends who they're professional
athletes and suddenly it was donald
trump saying to go outside and exercise
the democrats saying if you go for a
walk you're gonna you know kill your
aunt or whatever um all the wokeness all
my comedy friends who love dave
chappelle and even if they don't agree
with everything dave chappelle says
suddenly it's the left trying to censor
censor their favorite comedians who you
know i mean god when i was watching
chapel in new york he was going after
bush going after the war in iraq like
talking about the war on drugs like he's
always been a liberal dude um
i'm watching these people go from
disenfranchised i'm sick of the left i
guess i'm not really a democrat maybe
i'm independent to a lot of them just
going you know what conservatives are
cooler right now i'm just gonna i'm
gonna go i did a show in houston and
there were these three little goth kids
in the front row and they were tattooed
and they were like 21 or something and i
asked them i thought they were super
liberal i'm like what's it like being
liberal in houston and they were like
nah f that man we're conservatives and i
was like you look like undercover antifa
agents like what is happening like gill
bro watch this prageru video
yeah you want to go do dmt and talk
about the free market like it was that
and it's like yeah man
we are pushing these people away like
i'm it has nothing to do with privilege
or wealth like i'm talking to normal
people i've lived in arizona and texas
the last couple years not in brooklyn
not in los angeles and yeah
and and their grievances are valid i
don't know if that would make me full
conservative but the stuff that pushed
them away i don't disagree with
are you sure are you sure the left is
pushing them away or maybe turning point
usa is just making really good memes
that's it
i gotta tell you uh so so uh
it was six months ago that i was a
hardcore socialist
uh authoritarian uh uh you know just
absolutely and um i wore i wore uh
uniforms every day and then charlie kirk
smiled at me yeah it was like a vault of
lightning oh my god it was another james
o'keefe setup dude why'd you let charlie
cook smile at you like that they got you
got me
no this is interesting because um
like
the left is in my opinion has gone
absolutely insane and it's exemplified
in a lot of ways one i love playing this
video from the juice media
it's an old video from twitter i briefly
thought you said from the geomedia and i
was like well here we go
this is about this
this is the episode my last name is
killstein everyone calm down you're like
i'm coming here not to get cancelled
all right well let's play it hit up the
g media everybody the juice juice
they're actually like orange they do
produce a lot of progressive stuff today
but um
there's this guy hugo faran i'm probably
pronouncing your name wrong hugo he did
a thing called rap news and rap news 6
is about cablegate with julian assange
in this in this video
they're defending the release of uh
effectively defending the release of the
cables from wikileaks
criticizing hillary clinton as the
secret terry keeping secrets on the
public and threatening to prosecute
assange because the australia is in the
american empire and they control the
stuff alex jones is in it screaming that
the globalist not comey nazi fascists
are coming hell yeah so so that
depiction of of jones is is the 10 years
ago when he was like the government is
evil and they're trying to take over now
they're claiming he is a nazi he says in
the end they're trying to turn back the
clock on freedom of speech
and so i'm like if you praise julian
assange
say that they're trying to turn back the
clock on freedom of speech say hillary
clinton is is bad or wrong and depict
alex jones someone fighting nazis you
are right wing but that video was
progressive left in 2010. now of course
you could say well that's just what
happens conservatives you know people
who are progressive eventually the whole
society culture shifts left and i'm like
no no hold on there a minute that's
that's ridiculous though that's a great
point i i remember you know in my super
progressive days being like the clintons
are tied to goldman they're corporate
blah blah blah then trump goes they're
tied to goldman and it's like well he
hates women
you know now what trump left out is like
well he's also part of the swamp right
like so is his team like they're all
corporate hacks
however
it was
it's also true like i've been saying
that about clinton forever liberals have
been saying that about clinton's forever
this is why i didn't vote for trump in
2016. i i'm like i don't but i don't buy
it i don't believe it i don't care uh in
his first term trump does a point you
know i'll always just say bolton warhawk
was one of the worst ideas nuts and and
he had to get rid of him and bolton
betrayed him and and there was there
were several people that he brought on
but i quickly then saw that trump was
whatever he is
outside of that establishment
order he was no new wars he was uh
pulling our troops out of the middle
east and i was like i'll take what i can
get and if if biden's the other other
choice then uh you know then i'm gonna
i'm gonna vote for trump so i feel like
elon i feel like wow i guess i'm gonna
vote for you know this guy but even
vox.com said trump was moderate right
and i still that was back in 2016 and i
still was like i'm not going to play
this game but now you you let's let's
let's throw it back to what we what we
had last night when matt bender was here
i'm uh traditionally
like my political position is that of
like a 2012 liberal democrat you know
probably not i wouldn't even call it
moderate or centrist and the argument
the left says is if you have stayed the
same place 10 from where you were 10
years ago then of course today you're
conservative because the younger
generation is is more progressive and
that's what happens right like
they say things like yeah and then
people from 1954
were like this 1964 civil rights act is
too much change i'm just a regular
person from 1954 and i'm like
eugenicists in the 1900s and 20s also
thought they were the future they were
not they were wrong just because you
have ideas doesn't mean they're the
future you could be wrong so i'll say
this to the elon thing i thought it was
absolutely fascinating that we had on a
progressive who was arguing with me and
my position is pro-choice
and he was like we were so far apart in
our view on abortion that he was he
believed i was conservative
and sheamus is the conservative lifer
dude i think you're the
yeah
i think i think he wanted you to be
pro-life more than i want you to be
pro-life i agree like the the the
arguments were right and you want to do
it for babies he wants to twitter
[Laughter]
but no yes
but no it's funny because it's uh this
is something you and i have argued about
like a number of times on the show the
abortion issue
yeah we've got heat like tim is not on
the like conservative side of the issue
definitely not it's the traditional
liberal side i'm glad that you guys make
lydia be quiet during the year i know
that's the only good thing about this no
she's you know what i guess
suicide she's trying to oh i don't i
follow her on twitter yeah yeah i see it
and my old woke brain is like i can't
argue with her she's a woman
horrible yeah that's when you pull the
woke card anytime someone tries to go
after your pro-life be like uh my body
my choice um yeah i you know and and the
button not to be too
earnest but the the the bummer of that
is when i'm talking to someone i mean
lydia and i were talking about abortion
because that's how i small talk uh
before we went on air like downstairs
and so that abortion yeah that's it
that's my first tinder date as there was
speaking into someone's microphone um is
when you have someone
who
is even moderately on your side
that is the time instead of looking to
pick them apart for twitter or whatever
that's the time to actually talk about
compromise so like lydia and i were
talking about and and me and her are
pretty far apart on this issue but we
were talking about things we agreed with
like things that um kids should be
taught like access to contraceptions or
sex ed or you know
whatever and
if one side just goes you want to kill
women and the other side just goes you
want to kill babies it's like well
there's not a ton of middle ground there
but if you find someone who goes
you know i
i'm pro-life but yeah in the case of
rape and incest like i'm torn that's
your opportunity to have a conversation
with them if you have someone who goes
i'm pro-choice but having an abortion
like man like six months in like that
seems kind of rough right that's your
chance for a pro-life person to have a
conversation and then you guys are
talking and then you can actually come
up with some sort of well how do we stop
unwanted pregnancies or how do we work
on that because that's a solvable issue
or well i think there's a couple things
not necessarily just like stopping
unwanted pregnancies like how do we find
a home for for children whose mothers
didn't did plan the pregnancy and then
also because one thing i would disagree
with is so i don't believe in any
exceptions but tim and i have
conversations about it pretty frequently
i do think the conversation can be open
but there has to be a belief that like
you can reason with the person i think
that's really important we've kind of
lost that and like in some cases it's
warranted unfortunately sheamus has made
some good points that even in the past
month i've my position shifted i
wouldn't it's it's not we call it the
first trimester
so so uh sheamus mentioned i was
thinking about this earlier you were
talking about how abortion was the
intentional killing of the baby and this
is like a month or two ago and i was
like no no no we're not talking about
that we're talking about if the term
pregnancy has to be ended for some
reason and then you were saying yes and
that abortion would mean killing the
baby and i said that's not true i was
wrong and then because yesterday we
pulled the cdc definition which
literally says an abortion is a
termination of a pregnancy that does not
result in a live birth
meaning
if you would legalize abortion
post viability due to the
risk
due to the pregnancy causing a risk to
the pregnant patient's health as the law
read you would be saying terminate the
pregnancy and not result in a live birth
why do that when you can just i know i
don't want to i don't want to get into
the issue i want to just make the point
that
that was sort of like a realization for
me so
my so so anyway i want to take it back
to the politics because otherwise we'll
just talk about abortion forever
it was it was fascinating
that
you know matt bender is a modern leftist
or you know progressive what do you want
to call it we used to be buddies and
he's he's arguing with me as though i'm
not pro-choice
because he said
that he believes a woman has the right
to abort a baby at nine months
electively for any reason
and and that's what we saw with eric
adams recently jenn sackey i think
before she left said joe biden believes
there should be no restrictions we saw
it with uh with northam we saw it with
kathy tran it i i read the bill from
colorado which outright says there get
this the colorado bill not only says
there can be no restrictions it says a
fetus embryo
or fertilized egg has no rights under
state law it gets crazier and it goes
back further than people realize in the
early 2000s obama as a senator voted
against the born alive act yep well so
uh
well would you would you say that that
is
the extreme version just like
these things being floated right now
about making miscarriages a crime or a
birth control crime like would that be
the extreme on the other end or would
you not equate the two because
babies well i don't know anyone who's
saying a miscarriage should be a crime i
haven't heard anyone argue that i think
people know that i think people will say
that like certain abortifacients uh
should be but i don't know that they're
talking about birth control in general
or contraceptives in general
yeah and i think uh
when we hear stuff like that it's it's
it's simple enough just be like sheamus
do you agree with that right do you
think this i don't think one odd but the
part of the problem is the full part of
that it's like the framing bothers me
because i
there's i don't know anyone i mean i
know a lot of pro-life people i don't
know anyone who says like a miscarriage
should be
realized but so so here's the the way i
see it it's like okay let's try and have
a conversation if someone is convinced
like i don't know i saw this story i
said it was true i'd be like okay well i
think that's wrong we agree well and
then i can also go oh i don't know yeah
i saw it on twitter maybe it wasn't you
know what i mean like i was even ashamed
on uh
on like a pro-life level i was sort of
ashamed that i didn't really
and again i've never said i was an
abortion expert i'm there are you know
feminists and whatever that know a lot
more than me but i there was a part of
me when i started getting republican
friends and this i just started rounding
them up and
this came out i was so used to
throwing out my pro-choice tweets i you
know had them locked and loaded know the
formula blah blah blah call ben shapiro
short whatever it is
if abortion is wrong then why is
benjamin
short explain that i should have thought
about it okay
to be honest i don't actually have an
answer to that question he doesn't have
me there
and so
and then suddenly my feed for the first
time in my life my twitter feed
is like yeah well i guess they just want
to kill babies and i was like wait
i don't want to kill babies and i
literally realized that i
i never had researched like you were
saying tim like i don't know when does
it feel when does it i
actually did not know the answer and i
think again if ever if people were
willing to go i don't know or if someone
if pro-life people instead of just we're
so used to we have to defend our stuff
we're on twitter we're we're you know
we're on the news we have to stick to
our stick to our talking point if you
can take a second to go
man like even you said you're you're not
for abortion in any cases but to take
that second to go dude i don't know what
it would be like to be a woman who was
raped and to have to give that baby to
term and yeah we should talk about it
i'm not for it but just i feel like
neither side will show empathy yes and
that's what we need to do and then we
can disagree and then we can talk but
probably if we're both showing empathy
we can go okay this person's actually a
decent human who you're doing what you
think is right right if you think you're
saving babies then i must look like a
monster right if i think i'm saving
women vice versa
i gotta disagree with you on this
the right is notorious for being memed
as the debate me side right bench bureau
why won't you debate me oh remember
right so when i if i make a youtube
video there's there's there's the
there's the um
the um the rule and the exceptions if i
make a video and i'm like i believe
you know conservative policy is or i
believe policy is wrong
conservatives will comment and they'll
make arguments at me if i say policy is
wrong and it goes against the left
they'll call my advertisers they'll
start contacting you know various
companies i'll start getting angry
emails i'll get death threats
so when we say when you say there's no
empathy
sheamus james and i can can disagree on
the issue you know every day and we
laugh together and we hang out together
oh no to be clear i was saying both
sides trust me i've been canceled like i
know the left does i was saying
um these conversations are important the
fact that you disagree and you can still
make jokes about it like that is what's
important and it's weird that right what
i'm saying i disagree it's not both
sides oh okay it is it is the rule on
the left and the exception on the right
the left will not tolerate deviance the
right might not but typically will
engage with was more likely to have a
conversation with you this is why we see
the elon musk poll this is why uh
this is why elon musk feels the way he
he does it's why so many people who
watch this feel the way they do
uh i mean i can't speak to your
experience but you look at not good but
people who are you're on the left and
then all of a sudden they destroy you
yeah and then people on the right are
sitting there drinking a beer like you
want a beer dude like tell us what
happened yeah i mean that that is
actually what happened yeah i was gonna
say you you said you rounded up a bunch
of right wing friends i think they
rounded you up like a liberal who got
canceled get over here
i was telling my friend the other day if
i wrote a book called from feminist to
freedom fighter i would be a billionaire
just me holding the flag in a giant red
pill uh i would have so much money you
know i'll i'll write it at this point
i've had enough of this good by the way
this whiskey is very very good and so
strong i take a sip and just my body is
just lit for five minutes see he knows
whiskey lauren doesn't she put that in a
paper cup
no no the only the only reason i'm not
hammered is because they warned me about
what lauren did and i was like
that's why it's next to my giant water
bottle i'm sipping it very correctly
lauren uh was just grabbed a thousand
dollar bottle of whiskey
and was just pouring it into a paper cup
and drinking it wow and then i didn't
realize and i looked over and i was like
lauren are you pouring the papi in the
paper cup and she's like what's that
what's this let's be real it's kind of a
flex it's a little bit of a flex
i'm like this is this is like a special
drink
i almost drank it out of a coffee mug me
and lauren are trash people
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there